nine of the men were arrested in and  around Cologne prosecutors say they're  part of a germany-based network that  supports Islamic state they're suspected  of recruiting fighters for is helping  those recruits travel to Syria and  raising money for is often by criminal  means isn't almost enabler glories of  schools and churches and other buildings  they took anything that was relatively  easy to convert into cash Germany's  interior minister says the arrests show  the government strategy is working he  recently outlawed any activities in  support of Islamic state but he warned  that Islamic state remains a threat in  germany via hub in blick we're watching  about 200 maybe 230 people we considered  to be threats further that means they  are people we believe could possibly  plan attacks a nun stuff Plan and the  ministry estimates about 1,000 more  people are Islamic state sympathizers  but Demacia warned it was virtually  impossible to constantly track all of  those individuals